[Music]
bismillah alhamdulillah assalamu alaikum
again we're greeting you with that
beautiful greeting of peace peace be
unto you today my next guest is gonna
come out in a second this is some
exciting we have an exciting topic there
we're going to be discussing in a minute
sex everywhere you go everything you see
is promoting sex and sometimes safe sex
is put in front of the word sex what
does this mean
condoms are being passed out at the
schools parents now the fathers used to
be able to have some kind of say of who
comes to see his daughter and nowadays
parents and fathers are being pushed
away a lot of times from from even
having a say and dating is prevalent so
we want to see how Islam how does this
way of life the way of life of all the
messengers how does it tackle this
subject what's the definition of safe
sex with my next guest who comes out in
a minute we're going to help you
understand this a little bit better
we'll be right back on the Deen show
[Music]
how much is his messenger a la la la
[Music]
there's only one Jesus was his messenger
no I did that maybe it maybe it's just
to break the ice
my next guest Imam Suraj what hi Salam
alaikum alaikum peace be unto you peace
be upon you my good brother thank you
for finding the time to be with us here
on the Deen show very excited to have
you know I want to thank you for
inviting me it's my great honor and
privilege to be here with you
mashallah I want to say this to your
audience that I've been following you
for a number of years on the line we are
very happy to support you and your great
efforts well I have something for you
too because we love our Imam and you
know in Islam we give the gifts so we're
gonna give some gifts really Thank You
skier on the Deen show thank you
this is something that is for you and
then you can share it with the other
people think you should I put it here
yeah our brothers from half date.com
they help us to do add our drive to
produce some Dawa videos and those are
the new DVDs for Dawa thank you so much
so please have a good time viewing them
and sharing them with the non-muslims
and everybody else now we're going to be
talking about sex we're gonna be that's
great that's a great topic sex great
topic and we're gonna put safe in front
of it
we gotta have saves that safe sex out of
you say you're having safe sex that's
the way to have it but you want to clear
this up what do we mean by safe sex
please let's get into this topic well
you know let me before we talk about
yeah I think there's two premises that I
think that before you talk about sense
whether it's safe or unsafe that the
audience have to talk about number one
is is our relationship with our
creator yes it is critical you know and
even though my name is Suraj Mahajan and
your name is Eddie but a real in reality
we Abdullah that means be the servant of
Allah Allah mentioned the Quran mahalik
to genuine answer Analia Madan I have
not created spirits nor humans except to
worship me so so so the first point that
we may differ with other people is that
everything we do we do for the Creator
everything whether eating food and
abstaining from certain kinds of food or
the intimacy with our wives whatever it
is we do it as a result of him
commanding us and when I say us I don't
mean just the Muslims and the followers
of Prophet Muhammad peace and blessing
upon them I mean every prophet so
whether you're a follower of Moses a
follower of Jesus or follower of
Muhammad peace and blessing be upon us
what I'm talking about refers to all of
them and that is that everything that we
do is not like but this what I want to
do no it's not what you want to do the
question is what do your Creator
what has he ordained for you so it's not
just arbitrary like my opinion your
opinion and what you just do what's good
for you it's it's what you're saying
well what you think is good for
something that you think that's right
also the first point I want to make talk
about safe sex is that it's gonna go
okay what did God say the greater what
did Allah say what did the Lord of the
Worlds what'd he say about the issue
this is not just a Muslim guy this is
the god of the heavens and everything in
one God
al-almost form and let merely do one
well anyhoo for one-handed and that's
why in the Quran Allah tells Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
to tell the people of the book the
Christians and the Jews Allah who now
what Allah how come white your God and
our God is one so there's only one God
it's not the God of the Muslims uh-huh
it's one God the same creator of the
heavens and the earth 3 and 1 or just 1
no uh-uh
just just one you don't want to play
tricks with mathematics not no
mathematics chill you don't eat you
don't chop him up like a pie none of
that right so number one the first one
is the first premise is that that God is
the one that created us and he's the one
to give us the commandments let me take
a second the the second premise was well
before you go on to let me just
interject now just on this if you can
add you said one does this God that we
worship knows I mean is there anything
like him does he have any children does
he have anything like his creation or
when just one of one of the things that
our scripture tells us which is the last
revelation to man given to Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
while a subcommittee ishe there is
nothing like unto Him he is unique
there's nobody like him
he doesn't have no wife you don't have
children so God is one he's the creator
of everything he was from the beginning
he's everlasting
he was he didn't give birth to anyone
nor was he born so that's the one which
I just makes so much sense yeah please
can the second thing the second premise
which is which is critical I once was
thinking about the Congressional Black
Caucus you've heard about the
Congressional Caucus and and though many
people know about them they don't know
the model of the Congressional Black
Caucus took the model of the
Congressional Black Caucus is black
people have neither permanent friends
nor permanent enemies just permanent
interests
they're permanent interests and the
reason I talked about them I'm talking
about the next premise is that it's very
is crucial and that is that every
commandment that Allah gives us is for
our own best interests it's wrong good
it's found good he doesn't need any of
these things No
so if he deprives us of something he
knows that that is best for us if if he
would give us something yeah that'd make
him makes it permissible he makes it
allow then it's good for us he makes it
her I'm not permissible then it's no
good for us so these two premises you
can't talk about sex or safe sex or
nothing until you talk about number one
what did God command for us you know
what's in our best interest now having
laid that foundation now we can talk
about safe sex and let me give you let
me give you some information let me give
you some background information that
thing is critical the who are you
familiar with who who who who talk to us
about who ate WH o World Health
Organization who okay they they said
that intimacy between men and women
happen on this earth every day a hundred
million times one day a hundred million
times about a hundred million times a
day let's hold right there we got to
take a break we'll be right back 100
million times a day intimacy has taken
place be right back on the Deen show
[Music]
survivor Hajj and the Dean show hundred
million times a day who is giving us the
statistics that sex is taking place
intimacy
yes 100 million times a day yes tacos no
well let me say this you know some
people is wrong but that most of that
takes place in New York City in Chicago
but think about that 100 million times a
day that's a lot
uh-huh
that results in 910,000 conceptions
today Wow 910,000 that results in
350,000 sexually transmitted diseases
aids herpes gonorrhea all these things a
day a day
Wow and you hold on to you see the last
one
the results are 150,000 abortions a day
those are little babies that are being
put to death
little babies being put to death every
day 150,000 around the world so the
consequences of sex while on the one
hand it's enjoyable we can't deny that
yeah God created it to be enjoyable
right but Allah says in quran do do la
little hard to do huh
and these are the boundaries of allah
just don't go past them now he wants us
to enjoy ourselves yeah with the
intimacy between a man and his wife
marriage of course only marriage because
other than that is out of the boundaries
like like a basketball game without foul
lines and everything gotta have found
lines yeah okay these are the perimeters
using permanent what God has said we
stay in those perimeters he says of this
stay in it because if you don't you're
gonna get that do you want to get
350,000 sexually transmitted disease
right you're gonna get 150,000 abortions
a day right this is as a direct
disobedience to Allah the Almighty yeah
now when you understand the beauty of
intimacy when a man and woman comes
together and the possibility of creating
new life yeah you know and you know it's
interesting recently I was reading the
Quran this is the what the verbatim word
of god almighty the Quran absolutely the
exact words of God okay it's not written
by you know some person who we don't
know it's not first not it's not even
the words approximate peace and blessing
upon them the Quran is the words of God
that was revealed to the last Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessing be upon him
even as God revealed the Torah to Moses
and revealed the injeel the gospel
Jesus gotcha so this is this last
revelation in the Quran so I was
thinking about the prophets right how we
love them we love all of them and and I
was thinking the other day about prophet
Moses in the Quran says Allah mentions
in the Quran and we inspired oh man
Moosa the mother of Moses mm-hmm Jesus
had a mother Muhammad had a mother and
her father Moses had a mother the father
yeah so the results of these that will
be gonna put Jesus in a special category
yeah come back to that moment but the
result of all of these prophets but the
results of their mother and father
getting together and look what they
produced they produced all of these
these these these great men so so the so
they redid the union of a man and the
woman and the pleasure can create such
beautiful people as the messengers of
God and the reason I put Jesus in a
special category because we know as
Muslims we believe that his mother Mary
was a virgin and and she didn't have
prophet Jesus didn't have a father
yeah what does the miraculous birth but
putting that aside you know no no woman
can get pregnant without a man yeah
somewhere there's a man involved but
we're just trying to get to know each
other you know I want to get married I
want to get down like you're telling me
but how do I get to know somebody you
know it sort of problem yes problem is
we have a lot of tasters tasters you
know taste testing that's driving there
you go all right you can't do that
yourself because what happens
the man says okay come on honey I want
to get to know you and then after he get
to know it
okay the next let me get to know you and
let me get to know you and let me get to
know you you know you remember Wilt
Chamberlain wheelchair the basketball
player the famous basketball yeah one of
the great basketball players ever he
bragged in his book that he slept with
20,000 women he got to know 23 got the
notes what if that's
and I just heard recently I was in the
um I was I was I was I was listened to a
radio station and I can't confirm it but
a parent quoted to what they said that
the president of Cuba Castro just now
you know recently maybe the last couple
of days said he slept with 35 women
$35,000 women so they fit up there in
this hundred million somewhere that's a
lot of women so as there are women I
mean and then what happens when you so
when you look at that uh-huh is like
okay that's ugly mm-hmm it's ugly and
what we tried to do is that a man and a
woman you know they come together they
get married first and then they have the
intimacy why because that's what God
said he said it and we as Muslims as
believers with his servants of Allah and
if he says it then it's good for us so
it's not your opinion now this is what
the crater saying it's not my opinion or
your opinion or anyone's opinion is what
to create himself is saying gotcha now
you're telling us that look that woman
she wants to get married and now the guy
she says I understand that but he's
different he's not like the rest what
you guys say about this well
unfortunately is like the rest because
he wasn't like the rest he would be a
god-fearing man and because they are
there others by the way Christians and
Jews who believe that you shouldn't have
intimacy until you get married it's not
something else just for the Muslims yeah
but other you know god-fearing people
because it's also in their scripture
yeah because we believe that all the
scripture comes from the same source
yeah it actually comes from God it comes
from Allah yeah so he's the same one
that revealed the taurah the injeel the
gospel and the quran' is the same one
God but how can it be that I mean even
in the high schools nowadays you'll see
that the condoms are being given out and
this is being promoted okay everyone is
doing it everyone is dating so you're
telling us everyone is wrong anyone let
me tell you something you know what see
the problem Eddie that we have in a
society that we give in yeah be given
right so we said well you know they
having sex anyway so give them a condom
I do agree no I mean let me be real with
ya I I do agree that you know if you're
doing it illegally yeah right then I was
then it's better to use a condom yeah
less chance of disease and you know
pregnant unwanted pregnancies and things
like that but I'm not giving in yeah
I'm we're saying is that you are not
have sex until you get married and there
are a number of high school students and
college students who live in by that
Creed who don't necessarily call
themselves religious people but
understand the dangers of having
intimacy before marriage so again it's
it's you know if you want to be the
servant of God then this is the price
that we have to we have to pay I give it
another example you know people like
alcohol do they drink people like to get
high like they smoke marijuana yeah well
as Muslims we can't God doesn't allow us
so we're not gonna smoke marijuana if he
gave us the permission to do it we would
do it yeah if you said we can drink
alcohol we could in fact the Muslims
drink alcohol Allah mentioned is a very
interesting verse in Quran let Tucker
abu-salha anthem soukara Hector Tyler mu
Mehta : oh you believe do not approach
prayer while you are intoxicated until
you understand what you're saying
this was revealed in the Quran before
alcohol became prohibited so there were
times there were times when Muslims
drink alcohol why it was permitted but
once the god almighty said stay away
from alcohol yeah you know it is an
abomination so then the Muslims they
stopped and and it is written that when
that ayat from the Quran is revealed
leave it alone that some Muslims who
were actually drinking but when the
revelation came they simply turned it
over and spilled it out in the streets
of Medina yeah and they said it was
flowing down the streets of Medina
because god almighty had said that it
wasn't permissible as long as God
permits it we can do it after he says
his program is prohibited then we can no
longer do it so with the first step be
that acknowledged that there is a
creator that he knows what's best he's
the most wise and now are there
consequences just like at work
you disobey your boss once twice you get
fired are there consequences for
following your passions and desires and
not following what your Creator told you
to do you know it's interesting that you
said that Eddie there are two
consequences huh two possible
consequences number one is right now
while we live in on this earth right now
and that's some of the things that I've
talked about those are sexually
transmitted diseases and and all the
other consequences of that or even
imagine a man sleeping with a virgin
woman she thinking that he's gonna marry
her and he sleeps with her and then
leaves her totally emotionally destroyed
sir huh absolutely totally destroys all
right and on the one hand on the other
hand you will see that God will let you
do it huh listen he let you do it even
they said this is this what I want and
you said well I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna do it god I'm gonna let you do it
but then the punishment in the hereafter
is something altogether different next
life now there is a next life and that
when this life is over that's not it's
we're gonna die that's a fact
Kunlun S&D cottonmouths allah says in
quran every soul shall taste of death
when are we gonna die
McEnaney Nelson enter muta in that be in
the land ki Tabon Magellan no soul can
die except by the permission of Allah
it's already written in the book so
we're gonna die a no question about that
ain't nobody lived forever Ronald Reagan
died yeah there you go
Mike refresh and die there you go okay
you and I will die I'm gonna die that's
just the way it is more than that
prophets die right so none of us are
exempt yeah but the point is is that now
we have to face him now created on the
day of judgment and Hannah's gonna judge
us for all the life that we live
everything that we did
he gave us Commandments now you got to
pay a price even in this country and
every country you have law yeah and if
you violate the law then you're gonna be
punished if man can can can create laws
and punish the people for violating
those laws like Bernie Madoff remember
him the guy who shipped people out of
billions of the
yeah he's in prison because he broke the
law you know people in prison they break
the law what about the law of God so in
the hereafter we'd be punished by God's
punishment if we if he doesn't forgive
us for committing that sin or violation
of the law of God we're gonna when we
come back god willing we're going to be
discussing some of the benefits of doing
it the right way doing it how your
Creator wants you on the Deen show
precautions sometimes when you're in it
you already been blinded by love how do
you not let it get that far to that
state precautions yeah you know there's
a there's a very interesting personal
Quran Allah says let talk wearables you
know don't go near fornication the mind
that don't do it of course don't do it
but not only don't do it don't go knit
and God in His infinite wisdom he puts
us in a situation he tries to put human
beings in a situation where they won't
get in trouble and I'm gonna give an
example you know here's a Muslim he's
ahe's a strong Muslim so believe I'm
strong and don't worry I can be alone
with this beautiful woman and I won't
touch up well maybe you won't yeah but
then again maybe you will because what
happens is that there's a tradition of
our Prophet peace and blessings be upon
him that said that when a man and a
woman are alone by themselves in
seclusion then Shaitaan the devil you
know that character mm-hmm he's a third
party and in Shaitaan the devil all he
wants to do is get us to disobey Allah
don't satanic forces are there they're
real these spirits are real Christians
talk about them Jews talk about a
Muslims talk about them call it the
devil call it sin call it Shaitaan call
them jinn whatever you want to call them
they're real spirits and they're
in the desire the evil spirits desire
for us to do wrong so a wise man doesn't
put himself in position where he may
disobey his creator this is why Allah
has given us the warning don't put
yourself in that position where you can
commit zina
so you don't want to be alone with a
woman who was not you of course your
wife or your or your or your or your
child or your sister or your mother you
don't want to be alone with a strange
woman by by yourself so so we take our
precautions yeah and then here you have
to police yourself you know my
something's very interesting very
interesting tradition I don't know
anyone more pious than Prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings pious he was in
Mecca and I don't know a city more holy
than Mecca he was in city in the city of
Mecca Don a month of Ramadan right
you're the messenger of God in the city
of Mecca during the month of Ramadan
during the last ten nights he was in it
took off he was in seclusion in the
Masjid and then one of his wives came to
visit him and after the visit he said
let me walk you home now here's the
Messenger of Allah in the city of Mecca
during the month of Ramadan walking home
with his wife and some of his companions
come by and they see him and they start
to walk quickly he called them back he
said this is my wife Messenger of God is
city of Mecca making things straight
putting things and making sure he's
letting us know to let them know I'm not
walking with no strange one yeah this is
my wife
how much more should we now we walk all
the time we know we walking we owe an
explanation to somebody we walking in
the street with a woman who's that woman
mmm
who's that woman that you're walking
with and so the protection of the
community is that when we walked into
the community and we see a man walking
with a woman and Muslim man walk with a
Muslim woman okay sure we should assume
that's his sister or his wife or we
should assume that but not necessarily
so so the protection of the Muslim
community is the brothers say Oh mm
survives by the way this this is my wife
safe sex
so that's safe sex
yes when we opened up the show we talked
about safe sex Hot Topic it's all over
sex sex sex now you put the safe we're
talking about marriage yes doing it how
you create I want you to do it that's
the only way and we're almost out of
time
now the precautions now some of the
benefits some of the benefits of sex is
that we are you actually you see this
big slide so we don't shun away from
this
it's not something that we're like we
hide our heads done it's a good thing it
is a good thing let me tell you
something it's natural that's the idea
God created it yeah and he created us to
have a good time we should have a good
time only without wives though within
the private house within the boundaries
that God has laid down for us so now
this is when men and women come together
they do it the right way in marriage the
brother he's getting really excited
something's building up the woman wants
to be held in love yes how do they go
about it the halau the permissible way
you got to find out the this woman who
is her guardian first of all who is her
is it her father who's the one is gonna
give her way because in Islam we respect
the father
we don't go sneaking around with his
daughter no sneaking around sneaking
around we respect the father we go to
the father and say you know sir I'm
interested in your daughter you know I'd
like to have a formal meeting and I like
for you to get to know me and to know my
family so this is the respect this is
the Brotherhood of Islam like you me
know I had to come hot that you have
only a free but you have only never seen
none of you really believes until you
want for your brother what you want for
yourself now if you you know you you you
you you you want someone to come to you
if you have a daughter you want someone
you respect to expect that young man to
come to you then why not go to that
woman's father a whole guardian is maybe
a father has died maybe it's a brother
maybe it's an uncle maybe it's a
grandfather but that's the way we do it
we you know we don't we don't sneak
around
we don't go to sneak around the hotels
and motels and back up people's car this
is ugly this is ugly to Allah and it's
ugly to civilize people we do it right
and in this joy and I tell you one thing
I tell you the truth when you sneak
around
you can't really enjoy it something
happens psychologically to you because
it's not it's not this is not right and
you know it's not right it's in your
very fitrah it's in your very nature to
know that this is not right so you don't
have to hide and sneak in wonder you're
someone that's watching me and you know
you have to do all of that that's the
beautiful thing about doing it the right
way that's the beautiful thing about
safe sex safe sex is only through
marriage no other way no other way
there's none of this dating in Islam
they know you the Rebbe said to me Imam
Suraj I'd like to take you what your
daughter to dinner yeah no problem you
can take my daughter to dinner you and
my daughter and me and you and me uh-huh
we get that's how we go to dinner okay
so go back like we started realize that
there is a structure a way for us to
live and that's according to not our
desires but the way the Creator wants us
to absolutely and if you want to do safe
sex do it in marriage you gotta do only
in men only in marriage that's what we
mean by safe sex that's the only safe
sex there is thank you very much for
being with us thank you God Almighty
Allah rewards you thank you so much
thank you
and thank you for sitting tight through
another episode of the Deen show we
really hope that you got to benefit it's
something rational logical that there is
a crater behind this magnificent
universe and everything in it and it's
only right that you acknowledge that he
loves you he has manifested his love
he's given you so much and now how do
you give back you give back by living
life according to how he wants you to
live and when you do that that's how you
get that peace that's how you become
successful not only in this life but
also in the next we'll see you next time
here on the Deen show until then so I'm
making peace be unto you no speech is
better than to do that was call people
to Allah and to do there were no
speeches better no nothing is better
than that is it true that if one person
under Allah giving you an ability to
guide someone for the law
mission the craters permission that was
better than everything in this world but
in the whole world and everything that's
in it
in another narration it's better than
the best of wealth but if we really felt
that Eddie would we not be getting out
getting down and this is something that
we encourage all the MSAs all the dowel
organizations the mustards to get this
we want to print more we give these to
the non misses for free for free for
free we want our brothers
[Music]
you
you
you